like I'm juggling the corporate world
and the entrepreneurship world I'm 27 by
the way so super young man I'm very
young and I still like like my heart's
pulling me in two separate ways like I
have a mentor at corporate world I love
the steadiness yeah but I do have a
couple of clients on the side doing some
marketing email marketing that kind of
thing how do you know do you like is it
just gonna come to me I think one of the
things will crack the mentor will get a
job opportunity somewhere that you're
not willing to move the side hustle will
get a huge client that's just [__]
like oh wait a minute I think a lot of
times when people have two things
working especially in the corporate and
entrepreneur thing they're not okay
enough with it just being that way for a
little while they feel like they have to
choose when they don't you can do this
exact thing until you're 32. and you'll
still be young as [__] yeah and then one
of them will become what you do I think
people put pressure on themselves for no
reason around an ideology I should make
a choice why if shit's working why make
a choice
what's up